[INAUDIBLE]
IKAI LAN: -- go in to new
APIs and new themes.
JEFF POSNICK: There we go.
IKAI LAN: As Jeff mentioned, the
show that we're going to
do for you guys today is we're
going to be talking about what
new developers experience when
they come to the YouTube API.
So I personally love YouTube.
I was talking to Jeff before I
joined this team about how
much I enjoy and I use YouTube
for everything I do.
And initially, I started
watching
silly videos on YouTube.
Like I started watching--
I don't know.
Name a silly video.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Cat videos.
IKAI LAN: Cat videos.
I don't watch cat videos.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Maybe
it's [INAUDIBLE].
IKAI LAN: Skateboarding dog.
But as I started to use YouTube
more and more, I
started to realize that
video is everything.
I use YouTube to learn
how to cook.
I use YouTube to figure out
how do I unclog my drain.
YouTube is the resource for
pretty much everything that
you can think about, pretty
much that you want to do.
So I'm sure that you've gone
on YouTube to learn about
snowboarding techniques.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah, I enjoy
also just watching from their
cameras and their
old snapshots.
IKAI LAN: Right.
So anyway, that was a very long
introduction to YouTube,
which you all know
what it is now.
So I'm going to talk about
the new developer
experience for YouTube.
Not a lot of people know that
YouTube has an API.
And when you start thinking
about the types of
applications you could build
once you have access to pretty
much every video in the world
on every subject you might
want, you can really build
some very compelling
applications.
And YouTube has been pushing
out more and more APIs that
allow you to do this.
And the three APIs that are
public right now that you can
start using right away are--
and in the order of
popularity, I think, are
the Player API--
JEFF POSNICK: Well, let's
not say popularity.
IKAI LAN: They're all
very popular.
JEFF POSNICK: They're
in our hearts.
IKAI LAN: In our hearts.
JEFF POSNICK: Yes.
IKAI LAN: First off, there's
the Player API.
And the Player API is what you
want when you have a web page
or some kind of HTML page where
you want to display and
control an embedded player.
So the Player API is what you
would use when you want to use
JavaScript or Flash to say, skip
here in the video, move
backwards, enlarge the
video, [INAUDIBLE].
What else am I missing?
JEFF POSNICK: You could
queue up new videos.
You could create kind of a
custom playback experience.
You could get rid of
all the controls.
You do have your own playback.
And you mentioned JavaScript
and Flash.
Just to make it clear, you can
do HTML5 video playback, too--
IKAI LAN: HTML video playback.
JEFF POSNICK: --if you didn't
feel like using JavaScript.
So we have a lot of really cool
stuff to offer in the
Player API.
IKAI LAN: So the Player API--
you could think of it as one
of the front-end APIs for
displaying and controlling
the actual videos.
But when you start using the
Player API, the second API you
really want to really make the
experience better, make your
app better, is the Data API.
And this is what I'll be talking
a lot about today--
or not too long, maybe 5
or 10 minutes or so.
And the Data API is what you
would do when you want to
query, say, what videos
have you watched--
with his permission
of course--
search by topic, find me.
JEFF POSNICK: Dog videos.
IKAI LAN: Dog videos.
Search by keyword.
And there's a lot
of interesting
stuff in the Data API.
It uses authentication,
so we'll talk a
little bit about that.
And the third one is the
Analytics API, which I'm not
too familiar with.
I've been on this team for
about a couple days.
So tell me a little bit about
the Analytics API.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
And again, we wanted these new
developer experiences.
So these are very
fresh Googlers.
And I'm happy to talk a
little bit more about
the Analytics API.
And this is a way of fetching
information about the videos
that are in your own accounts.
Again, this is another
authorized API.
You have to go through the OAuth
2 flow first, which I
know Ikai is going to
be talking about
it in a little bit.
And it lets you fetch pretty
much all the demographic
information that we have about
who's watching your videos,
how popular videos are
in certain regions.
We now have some information
about the total watch time,
which is really important for
folks who are looking to see
exactly how much of your videos
are being watched.
And we're pretty excited
about it.
It's currently in experimental
mode right now.
So it's not fully launched in
its 100% final state yet.
But we really do hope that
folks are using it.
IKAI LAN: Right.
And since it will be called
an offline API, you should
totally start using it if you
need this type of data.
Because even though, as Jeff
says, it's experimental, what
that means, as a Google
Developer, is that we may
still make lots of breaking
API change.
Now, we try really hard
not to do this.
We try not to break our users.
But when an API's an
experimental, that means that
we're still iterating
very, very fast.
We're still not quite sure what
exactly we want to do
with it yet.
So there might be breaking
changes.
But for the most part,
it should be working.
So since it's offline, maybe
you're pulling analytics to
build a dashboard, or you're
aggregating stats at night.
This is the sort of thing that
you would do with the
Analytics API.
And if that breaks, at least
you won't break users.
So I highly encourage it, if you
need this data, to start
using this right away.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit about--
I just cheated.
I just looked at the notes
that I put on my thigh.
I mentioned that the Data API is
something that you want to
get into if you're doing any
kind of YouTube application.
And to do the Data API, you
need to do authorization.
So I've been at Google
for over three years.
And before being at Google, I
worked at a place where I had
the opportunity--
opportunity?
JEFF POSNICK: I think
that would be--
IKAI LAN: The joy.
The joy to work with OAuth.
JEFF POSNICK: Joy-portunity.
IKAI LAN: Joy-portunity.
I had the joy-portunity
to work with OAuth.
And OAuth is this way of
authenticating requests.
Now, when you jump into the
Data API, you'll see that,
holy moly, there are
a lot of options.
You've got the Data
API v1, v2, v3.
You have ClientLogin
authentication--
AuthSub and OAuth.
What should you use?
I don't want to make any
absolute statements
except for a few.
I want to make a few absolute
statements.
JEFF POSNICK: Make as many
absolute statements as you
want, and I will qualify your
absolute statements.
IKAI LAN: All right.
Jeff will qualify.
And if Jeff starts to go
like this, don't do it.
So first off, don't
use the v1 API.
JEFF POSNICK: Do not.
IKAI LAN: Just do
not use this.
This is deprecated.
I don't know what's going
to happen with it.
Can you tell us?
JEFF POSNICK: I think it's going
to follow our normal
deprecation policy, basically.
And that's all dictated by our
terms of service, so I don't
want to extemporaneously talk
about what that involves.
But you could look
that up online.
And we're doing a pretty good
job, I think, of hiding the v1
API from our current docks.
And hopefully there aren't too
many new developers that
stumble upon it and say, hey,
I'm going to get started with
the v1 API.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
I still see a lot of
questions about the
v1 API online, though.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
IKAI LAN: So already, strike the
v1 API if you're starting
to jet-dive into the
YouTube API.
So now you've got the choice
of the v2 and the v3 API.
The v2 API is pretty much the
fully supported, mature
version of the API but doesn't
have quite all the
functionality we want.
And the v3 API is kind
of on its way there.
And if you're starting a new
project, definitely look at
what the v3 API can do, because
that's where we're headed.
That's where the puck is going,
so check that out.
And there are some things you
can't quite do with the v3
API, so keep that in mind
when you're designing.
Just, abstraction is good when
you're writing code.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
So the v3 API is another
experimental API.
And everything that you guys
said previously about our
experimental API policy and
adding new features and
perhaps introducing a
few breaking changes
also applies to v3.
There is not quite full-feature
parity yet.
There are some glaring
exceptions and things that are
currently in v2 that
aren't v3.
And if you need any of those,
then v2 is the way to go.
V3 has really nice
client libraries.
And I think that's the biggest
thing about v3 that makes it
nice for new developers getting
started, because you
have a really rich client
library experience, including
good support for OAuth, too.
IKAI LAN: A few things that we
have got to do on our end is
to really just build on those
client libraries and show you
guys how to build great
applications.
So right now, there
are examples in
JavaScript and Python.
And we're going to have examples
for many of the other
popular languages, too, like
Java, JavaScript, PHP.
I've been working on some Go
samples, only because no one
claimed those.
So I said, oh heck,
I'll do it.
So if you're programing in Go,
you're in luck, because
hopefully I'll be able to push
those samples out soon.
So the v3 API, even though Jeff
says it's experimental,
I've taken a look at the API.
And obviously I can't promise
this, but it looks pretty
close to what the final thing
might be, plus we might add a
few things.
So even though it's way later
along in its development and
being pushed out than the
Analytics API, which came out
in, I think, December--
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah, I don't
want to say that it's way
later along necessarily.
I think they're pretty
much both--
IKAI LAN: Qualify
my statements.
JEFF POSNICK: They're pretty
much both looking like what
the final version's going
to look like, with some
additional features.
That would be my not unofficial
answer about the
future of those APIs.
IKAI LAN: So what Jeff is
unofficially saying is that if
you can use the v3 API, it's
pretty safe to use the v3 API
and to start taking
a look at that.
Now obviously, with any
experimental API, you're best
off in an environment where
you can iterate quickly.
So a web environment's a really
good example, because
if there is a breaking change--
and there probably
won't be-- you can quickly
push out an update.
Because most of the breaking
changes we make to
experimental APIs tend to be
very, very small-- like we're
renaming this function,
or we're
changing what this returns.
So we do consider all these
things when we're pushing
things out, even for
experimental APIs.
So on that note, v2 and v3 are
your different options.
Now, I mentioned earlier, maybe
you want to write an
application that says, help me
look at my favorite videos and
do something with them.
Now, you don't need to write
this application, because
YouTube has a feature
called Favorites.
And you can just go and look.
But let's say you want to do
something interesting with
these, like you wanted to--
JEFF POSNICK: You wanted to take
a look at your favorite
videos and find all the topics
that are associated with those
videos, using v3 is awesome
support for Freebase topics,
for instance.
IKAI LAN: You want
to translate all
the titles into Russian--
Roman Nurik is producing
for us.
We'll translate them all
into Russian and
email them to Roman.
These are all things
that you could do
programmatically via the API.
And you need authentication
to get this done.
I can't just write
an application.
Jeff can't just show up, and
I'll automatically know who
Jeff is, because that's bad.
It's not a bad thing, it's that
if I'm a bad person, that
would be bad, because then I
would have accessed your data
and your YouTube, and I'd be
able to act on your behalf.
JEFF POSNICK: And I will qualify
that by saying Ikai's
not a bad person.
IKAI LAN: I'm not
a bad person.
JEFF POSNICK: Ikai does not
want to act on my behalf
unless I tell Ikai to
act on my behalf.
IKAI LAN: And thus we have
this concept of OAuth.
So when you're authenticating,
you have three options to
authenticate.
So when Jeff comes to your
application, and you want to
say, hey Jeff, let me
do stuff for you.
Let me create interesting
content for you.
Jeff has to somehow give me
access to his account.
And there are three ways
of doing this.
One is called ClientLogin, where
Jeff directly gives me
his username and password.
Please don't do this.
We don't want to support
this anymore.
It trains users to give their
usernames and passwords to
third-party sites.
In general, taking the username
and password is a bad
practice, and I don't want
to encourage this.
JEFF POSNICK: And you can't
actually do it in v3 anymore.
So we don't have support--
IKAI LAN: You cannot do
it in v3 anymore.
JEFF POSNICK: --for
ClientLogin in v3.
IKAI LAN: The second way is
something called AuthSub.
And AuthSub is a little
bit better,
but it's not a standard.
It's a standard across what we
call GData across Google APIs,
but that's going to be slowly
overshadowed by OAuth.
So AuthSub works a little
bit better.
AuthSub works like this.
Jeff comes.
I'm a service provider.
You are YouTube.
I'm just going to
act this out.
Jeff goes to me.
And I go, hey, I want to
translate all your favorite
videos into Russian, or
at least the titles.
JEFF POSNICK: Yes, I do.
IKAI LAN: You want this.
So Jeff comes to me, and he
says, hey, I'll give you
access to my videos.
I don't just have access
to his account.
I need to go and kick him into
YouTube, where YouTube asks
him, hey, do you trust Ikai?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Do
you trust Ikai?
JEFF POSNICK: Pretty much.
Yes.
IKAI LAN: So now he throws
him back to me.
And when YouTube throws Jeff
back to me, he gives me a
token that I can use to make
API calls on his behalf.
And that's roughly what
AuthSub does.
And OAuth is more or
less the same way.
OAuth is the same thing.
We call it the three-legged
flow, because
there are three legs.
It's very confusing
by the way.
There's a three-legged flow
where Jeff goes to me, I kick
him to YouTube, and
I say, hey, let me
access this guy's account.
And YouTube says, yes,
you can access.
Or Jeff says, you can access,
and YouTube gives me a token.
Now, as part of this--
JEFF POSNICK: Sorry, just to
elaborate on that, everything
that we're talking about here
also takes place within the
context of a web browser.
So this is all being done on
a web page that's hosted by
Google or YouTube.
I think it's actually hosted
by a google.com demand.
So you're entering your password
and username on a web
page that's hosted by Google.
Or if you're already logged in
to your Google account, you
don't even have to enter any
of your credentials.
It's really just clicking
Authorize or whatever.
IKAI LAN: And a user comes in,
and the user sees https://.
As long as you don't get a
certificate warning and ignore
it like most users do--
I'm rolling my eyes--
then the user is protected
from phishing
and things like that.
Obviously, you're not protected
from keylogging, but
this isn't the Security GDL.
Ha ha ha.
We're talking about OAuth.
So OAuth takes us a little bit
further with the concept of
what's called scopes.
As an application, if I'm
translating Jeff's videos, I
want a small scope
as possible.
I really only want
read-only access.
So I ask YouTube only for
And when Jeff goes to YouTube to
authenticate, YouTube says,
well, this app just wants
to look at your videos.
So Jeff says, OK, well, an
application that translates my
favorite video titles
into Russian
doesn't need write access.
Why would it need to
upload videos?
Why would it need to like?
Why would it need to
comment as me?
It doesn't.
So he can safely authenticate.
And that's just one more layer
of protection OAuth provides.
JEFF POSNICK: And that's
actually something that's only
supported in version three
of the Data API.
Unfortunately, we didn't have
that sort of fine-grained
scopes in version one, version
two of the Data API.
You kind of had to request a
scope that had full read-write
access to your YouTube
account.
So that's another good reason
for the benefit of your users
to migrate to v3, in that you
could even request a minimal
set of permissions, and make
your users feel better about
what you're asking for.
IKAI LAN: Let's do a quick
review of some of the things
that we've talked
about so far.
And I'll review again
and again and again.
So there is OAuth.
There is v2 and v3.
And we just talked
about scopes.
So these are a lot of concepts
you'll be seeing over and over
as you're going through the
sample application in the
documentation.
Now, I've left out one more type
of API which is also a
very interesting type, which
is developer key
authentication.
You need developer
key for this.
You need keys for
OAuth as well.
And you get to these
via the cloud--
or not cloud the cloud,
the API console.
So I don't know the exact URL,
but you could search for
Google APIs console, and
it will come up.
JEFF POSNICK: And we've actually
had previous YouTube
Developer Live talks where we
featured the whole workflow
for requesting access to
these APIs and stuff.
Probably on our Google+ stream,
we'll post some links
back to those old shows that you
could watch and see that.
IKAI LAN: So you go to the APAC
console, and you say,
give me YouTube access,
give me YouTube
Analytics API access.
And they'll give you the
different keys you
need to work with.
Now, developer key access.
Sometimes when you're writing
an application, I don't need
access to Jeff's account
or Roman's account
or Ibrahim's account.
All I need is to say, search
for dog videos.
And you could do this using
just developer key.
We don't need the three-legged
OAuth for this.
We just need developer key.
And in v3, you can just append
this to the end of a URL, a
REST URL, and say,
give me back the
data, and that'll work.
And you get the developer
key via the API console.
So what do you need for working
with the YouTube API?
You need to go to
the API console.
I keep leaving this out, but
that's one of the most
important things.
JEFF POSNICK: So this is
actually another way that
version two and version
three differ.
In version two, we did
actually support
anonymous API access.
You could use a developer key.
And confusingly, it was a
different type of developer
key than what we're
talking about here
from the API console.
But in v2, it's optional.
In v3, you do need to put a
developer key or use OAuth 2.
It's an either/or situation
for all your requests.
IKAI LAN: Jeff, when you used
v2 and you didn't use a key,
what were the limitations
that you would run into?
JEFF POSNICK: It's basically
a quota issue.
IKAI LAN: What's it quoted on?
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
So we--
IKAI LAN: Did you notice
there was a trap there?
I trapped you.
JEFF POSNICK: I'm going to
also say that we have me
talking about quota for 30
minutes in a previous GDL,
which is super, super
entertaining.
It just tells you how big
an issue this is.
There is like 30 minutes worth
of content to talk about.
But basically, in any of our
Data APIs, there is a quota
imposed on kind of the rate of
API calls that you can make.
And what we would do in version
one and version two,
if you were using a developer
key, there's a little bit more
accountability.
And accordingly, we would grant
a slightly higher quota,
so you can make a larger number
of calls before you
start getting rate limited.
We also do have quotas in
version three, slightly
different than the way
version two quotas
work, though, basically.
It's a way to protect from
a bunch of things.
I think, Ikai, if I remember
correctly, when you were
learning Go--
I don't want to say anything
about your skills--
IKAI LAN: Oh, you can say
anything you want.
JEFF POSNICK: I believe you
walked away from your desk
during lunch while you had a
loop running, and you blew
through your quota.
IKAI LAN: I might have
had an infinite loop.
I might have had an infinite
loop running.
Made a mistake.
JEFF POSNICK: We want to partly
protect developers from
doing that sort of thing
inadvertently and sending
potentially unbounded number of
requests against our servers.
Eventually, we started saying,
hey, we're going to start
rejecting these requests.
IKAI LAN: So that's
another reason.
That's what that developer
key is for.
So again, the concept that you
need to understand when you're
working with the YouTube API
are-- or at least have some
kind of knowledge of-- are
OAuth, v2, v3, a developer
key, the API console, and
there's code samples.
I think that's what you need.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
I think a lot of folks probably
get started using the
code samples, which is why I'm
really glad that you're
working on some.
And we're going to put Ibrahim
soon to work on writing some
more code samples for v3.
IKAI LAN: There's a lot of
confusion around these topics
sometimes, and that's why we
like to teach them as many
times as possible.
So that was my spiel.
I know I went on and on, but
that's what I had to say.
And I'm sure that over the
coming shows that I'll have a
lot more to add to this topic.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
That's good.
IKAI LAN: I'm sorry
for totally just
monopolizing the time.
JEFF POSNICK: No, this is
exactly what I wanted to get
out of the show.
And Ibrahim, though, we didn't
give you too much of a chance
to ask anything.
And I don't want to also put
you on the spot, but if
there's anything you wanted
to bring up from your
experience--
You've been here on the
YouTube team one
week less than Ikai.
This is a little below
your third day--
third day on the team and
third day at Google.
IKAI LAN: There were
vacations, too.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah, there
were some vacations.
So anything?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah, maybe
I will ask about--
you talked about the Data API,
Player API, and Analytics API.
Is there a new starter
building your
own website or app.
How do they all fit together
into the big picture?
How do they play handy?
Or is it better to start from
one API and start using the
other ones?
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
So they all do fit together
pretty nicely.
And we do have some samples.
The samples we have, for
instance, with the Analytics
API, also include making calls
to the Data API just because
you kind of have to.
You need to get some information
from the Data API
first before you could use the
Analytics API effectively.
You need to know what the
channel is that you're running
the Analytics API
report against.
So our samples for using the
Analytics API also do show the
relevant Data API calls.
IKAI LAN: So the bigger question
here is the use case.
I'd like to come back from a
use case or to what kind of
app are you designing?
Because the apps that you're
designing might not use all
three APIs.
But I think that there are lots
of apps where when you
show a player, you usually want
to make data calls also.
But it depends on the app
that you're building.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
So there are really common use
cases where you want to play
back a video but also display
metadata about that video,
show the title and description,
or do a search
and have the snippets.
And all these are cases where
you're going to want to
integrate the Data API and the
Player API, or the Data API
and the Analytics API, like we
talked about, and potentially
all three within applications.
I think we do a pretty good job
of having some samples out
there that show real, working
pieces of code.
We maybe don't do the best job
of highlighting them directly
from the docks, so I'm not
sure that we can--
IKAI LAN: Well, let's
fix that.
That's what we're here for.
Gung ho.
JEFF POSNICK: That's something
that we certainly should do.
So we tend to blog
about things.
And I don't know if you guys
have had a chance to go back
through our five-, six-year
archive on our--
IKAI LAN: Six-year archive?
JEFF POSNICK: --on our YouTube
API Developer's blog.
So we certainly can't expect
everybody who's getting
started with the API to know
that we had a blog post from
three years ago in which we
talked about this cool,
open-source app that put
together all these different
APIs in a real-world fashion.
So yeah.
Let's work a little bit on
discovery for that, I think.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Maybe another
broad question is a new
starter, is I'm using
these APIs.
And if I ever have some
problems, or if I think that
there's something not working,
or maybe I'm having some
difficulties, what's the best
way to escalate these issues
or file it back?
IKAI LAN: I think you
can go to Jeff.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Or like the
fastest [INAUDIBLE]?
IKAI LAN: Don't do that.
JEFF POSNICK: Well eventually,
you're going to be the ones
answering these.
So until that time
comes, yeah.
So right now, we're asking most
of the questions that
come from developers
out there to go in
through Stack Overflow.
That's the best place for
general questions about the
API, not really for bug
reports or for future
requests, though.
So if you're in the situation
where you really just are
saying, hey, how do I do this in
this certain language using
the v3 Data API, that's
a great thing to
ask in Stack Overflow.
It's probably indicative of
the fact that our samples
aren't good enough to help you
right now, so apologies in
advance about that.
Or just general questions about
why something isn't
working exactly as you'd expect
it, that's OK for Stack
Overflow, too.
But then we also have a separate
issue tracker that we
use for reporting bugs or for
making future requests.
And that just makes it a little
bit better for keeping
track of things on our end.
We have this public thing that
we could refer to and say,
hey, this is where the request
came in for this
feature in the API.
We can tell the Engineering
team, hey, we have 20 people
that have starred this request,
and it's pretty
important that we
implement it.
And it also just kind of plays
nicely with the Stack Overflow
community, because they have a
very large and established
community on Stack Overflow
in general.
And they have some guidelines
as to what you should and
shouldn't ask there.
IKAI LAN: What's nice about
Stack Overflow, too, is that a
lot of times someone comes and
asks an API a question, and
it's actually a Java question--
like how do I parse
to JSON the API returns?
You could definitely use the
client libraries, or you can
just use it without the client
libraries and do things raw.
And that'll work
perfectly well.
But you'll get back JSON and
want to say, well, how do I
parse this JSON?
Well, it's not really a
YouTube API question.
JEFF POSNICK: Yes.
And there's tons of folks
on Stack Overflow.
Honestly, the thing I like best
about Stack Overflow is
that folks not on the core
team have been answering
YouTube API questions, which
is wonderful, because it
really does foster more
of a community.
And it means that we don't
necessarily have to be your
only source of authoritative
answers out there.
IKAI LAN: Now, I have an
add-on question to what
Ibrahim asked, which is that on
some teams at Google that
provide APIs, they also have a
Google group, which you would
use for like meta discussions.
Now, Stack Overflow is good
for coding questions.
It's not very good for more
general either policy
questions or hey, what's up?
So is there a place for that?
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah, so
there used to be.
We did have a very active
Google group, actually.
So that is no longer around.
We did deliberately make the
change from the Google group
model to Stack Overflow.
And we did lose a little bit in
terms of being able to have
those meta discussions, have
things that aren't necessarily
best fit for the future
requests or bugs
on the issue tracker.
What I'd probably tell you to do
is phrase it in a way that
is more feature request-y or
buggy, and put it in the
public issue tracker rather
than putting it on Stack
Overflow in that case.
We do have our YouTube for
Developers Google+ page.
And occasionally, people share
things directly with us and
ask us things there.
Not necessarily the best way
to get in touch with us,
because it is a little hard
to maintain that.
We kind of deliberately made
the move towards fewer
channels for communication, so
we could focus a little bit
more on each channel and make
sure that we had as close to
100% of the things that come up
in each of those channels
addressed as possible.
So it's kind of a trade-off,
but we had to make that.
Maybe now that the teams are a
little bit bigger, we'll--
IKAI LAN: Well, and we're
always learning, right?
We're always learning about
what model works for what,
because I think Google groups is
very good for a few things.
What gets really bad
is when there's
crossing of the streams--
"Ghostbusters"--
is when people start asking
coding questions on the groups
which are way better for Stack
Overflow, when people start
asking policy questions on Stack
Overflow, which you're
going to get down
voted real fast.
JEFF POSNICK: Cool.
IKAI LAN: Did you have
anything else?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: I think
that was like my
first, beginning question.
IKAI LAN: They're very, very
good ones, because I don't
think about these
things too much.
So it's always good to have a
new perspective, a fresh set
of eyes on things.
JEFF POSNICK: Awesome.
Cool.
Well, that's probably it for
the show for today then.
IKAI LAN: We're running
out of time.
JEFF POSNICK: I know that when I
checked the Google Moderator
queue for the show right before
the show started, we
didn't have any questions
from the general
community out there.
So apologies if you added
a question since
this show has started.
We'll try to get your question
next week, in that case.
We kind of, at the end of each
show, peg the fact that Google
Developer Relations is hiring.
YouTube Developer Relations has
obviously recently made
some hirings.
But Google Developer Relations
in general is still hiring.
And--
IKAI LAN: What locations
are we hiring in?
JEFF POSNICK: I think we're
hiring pretty globally.
IKAI LAN: We're hiring in
Mountain View for sure.
New York City, I know
we're hiring.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
Definitely in other areas
of the globe as well.
But I think the most
authoritative source for that
sort of information is
developers.google.com/jobs.
So if you're out there, and you
think you might want to do
what we're doing-- just sitting
around and talking--
IKAI LAN: You know what we
should do is, one of these
days, we should do a show
about what we all do.
And we'll bring one guy
from every team out.
I don't know how we're
going to do it here.
JEFF POSNICK: A "Mr.
Rogers" type show.
IKAI LAN: Let me give you
guys a sneak preview.
Now, we're usually not allowed
to do this, but
I'm kind of a renegade.
We're working on getting
a better studio.
JEFF POSNICK: We've got to
get a censor button.
IKAI LAN: We're trying to
get a better studio.
Roman's pushing the big, red,
kick-him-off-the-air button.
We're trying to get a better
studio space here now.
In Mountain View, they have a
great studio space where they
have shows where they can
put five or six people
comfortably.
They've got multiple cameras.
We've got one camera, sometimes
two in this studio.
One time we should make a show
about behind-the-scenes, so
you could see how
we work here.
But we are working on
getting a slightly
better studio space.
Hopefully, that works
out for us.
JEFF POSNICK: There you go.
Yeah.
A couple weeks ago-- for folks
who were watching, I think it
was our show with
[INAUDIBLE]--
and then at the very tail-end
of the show, there was
somebody who was doing
construction work in the room
right behind us.
And it sounded exactly like
somebody was breaking into--
IKAI LAN: Was doing
construction?
JEFF POSNICK: --into a
bank vault's inlay.
Well yeah, it was drilling and
a few other background noises
that hopefully will not happen
in this new studio space that
Ikai leaked.
I don't know.
I don't know if that qualifies
as a leak, but--
IKAI LAN: That's going to make
it to the top of CNN or Wall
Street Journal.
You didn't try to
play it off as--
we intentionally put those
sounds in, because it's like
you're constructing
applications.
Ooh.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JEFF POSNICK: Now that
we have your--
your improv skills, right?
IKAI LAN: Anyway, we've gone
away with time, now.
We love talking to you guys.
So hopefully, you'll join us for
the next GDL, which is--
JEFF POSNICK: I don't know.
Oh, it's next Wednesday.
IKAI LAN: It's next Wednesday.
JEFF POSNICK: At 10:00 AM
Pacific and 1:00 PM Eastern.
I do not know what the topic
is, but stay tuned probably
next Monday when we
announce them.
IKAI LAN: And you'll
find these shows at
developers.google.com/live is
where to find a schedule.
You'll also find a lot of
other great shows, so
definitely check
that site out.
JEFF POSNICK: Cool.
All right.
Congratulations on getting
through your first show.
Bye, everybody.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
That was great.
Bye, everybody.
IKAI LAN: Bye, guys.